it's not like where you have recently
it's all over uh the media you had will
smith
it was a jada picket is that his wife
yeah and you ride together
we got together bad marriage for life
and this is common where the husband and
wife separate
and you know what happened from there
yeah
yeah i mean this is not this is like
they they
so i mean because you say we go back to
islam we go back to the way that the
creator told us to live
so this is not like jumping to another
partner and i'll go experiment here and
there and then come back and
uh eddie do you have any idea of how
much
infidelity is happening with practicing
muslims
we're not even talking about will smith
and jada this is actually in the
comments
i'm talking about muslims i'm talking
about muslims muslims
how far they're doing infidelity we're
just looking at all those of course
they're not muslim muslims who are
practicing
i was talking to a family therapist and
the person was telling me that one of
their clients are two people who go to
fajr
at the masjid they pray fajr at the
masjid so they're practicing muslims
they're both sleeping with different
people
i mean we are living in this generation
the reason why you and i don't hear
about these things
is because we are not family therapists
we're not we don't
it's not like these things that come to
us right we only know what we
what was within our bubble within our
sphere of knowledge right
it's like people publicly talk about
this stuff but if you're a family
therapist
and you and you bring this and you and
they can tell you a whole different
world
of what they know from practice oh
you're just in secular muslims or just
muslims by name how about practicing
muslims
and how much infidelity there is i just
recently heard from something
just locally in my area and it's like
what
yeah this person does this and this girl
does this and like what in the oh
she want to stop with somebody because
he slept with somebody and you could
talk about practicing muslims
what like to me it's kind of like
there's a lie you don't cross
like no matter how angry i get with my
wife there's certain words i will never
utter to her
but it's like people don't have that
line so if you don't have that line
then why are you surprised when we are
falling to the same traps as non-muslims
fall into
you know if we don't have if we don't
take our deen seriously we don't care
about islam
and some of you like oh i don't like all
these rules okay fine do whatever you
want
but as soon as you have zero rules and
she has zero rules
and you have a big and the anger comes
and disputes come and shaitan comes and
whispers
you are now left open like everybody
else and all these other things start
entering our muslim community that was
never there before and become normal
unfortunately in our muslim community
that was never before it was a very i
was going through a magazine yesterday
bro and i'm going to my old mag my kids
were cleaning up
the room and i was going through this
they came across the box in the bubble
you have a magazine
and i was like what we had this magazine
for is islamic magazine oh i think
half of our dean sponsored uh article or
something in there a while back or maybe
help
the magazine so we kept a copy of that
article just from memory
and as i'm going through the thing i
came through one of the marriage
things uh one of these uh things about
men and women
uh a couple that was very popular here
where i live
everybody want to put them on
commercials or put them on ads and for
islamic organizations
they were the couple that brother left
the sister
got divorced for another man
look at this place and i'm talking about
some random brother this is like one of
the most popular brothers in our
community it's kind of like the stuff
that's happening now
is kind of like what what well what do
you want
would you guys want to sisters in salah
no problem you want to have men who are
not no longer men and women who are men
no problem well guess what now we have
problem
because now when you open pandora's
boxes
everything goes we're not using quran
sunni anymore we can just use your logic
your desire well his desire is another
guy
what are you going to say to them they
have children may god almighty the
creator of law
guide since we mentioned will smith and
jada pick it and give them to the
solutions islamic solutions make
allah help guide the muslim communities
keep us
all guided and help us to stick by the
the guidance that he sent the quran to
the sunnah thank you so much my brother